[Inaudible] hopefully at the end of this challenge,
the two of them are still going to be sleeping in the same bed. Excuse me,
not fiving. You got to get writing, not even a game anymore.
Welcome to song lab,
a show where our talented song lead producers get paired up with musicians and
have only two hours to create an original song.
The most voted salt will be the winner and the team will get a cash prize.
Get ready for song lab.
Okay.
Hi everyone. We have here with us, our super talented song, lap producer.
What's up everyone. My name is Tara evergreen.
I am a producer and I predominantly make vocal driven indie electronica. Hey,
my name is Simon Zurvita and I'm a producer from Toronto, Canada.
I mainly do hip hop production right now.
Then we brought two special musicians who also happened to be a couple.
I see.
My name is Brian shin. I'm a singer song writer and yeah.
[Inaudible]. My name is Kayla [inaudible] and I am a recording artist,
singer and songwriter.
My relationship with Kayla is fire.
I met him at a bar like three years ago and I was just like, Hey, you know,
I'm Kayla. He wasn't into it. Cause I guess I was too bubbly.
And he was like real chill.
He fell in love with me after we both had a bottle of fantasy is a way better
singer than I am. He can play multiple instruments and produced anything.
I do wish I could play an instrument. I did play the harp,
but I don't know how to play that no more. Actually. You know,
if someone brought a Harper round, do you guys live together?
He is in the other room. Yeah.
Well now we need to decide what the teams are going to be three, two,
one. And the results are Brian.
You will be on team evergreen and Kayla you'll be on a team.
It's not even a game anymore for today. Song battle. That theme is
breakups. Mike let's go. Okay. Team Simon.
The three words for your teams lyrics are missing
jealous and ex team evergreen.
And the three words for your team's lyrics are here.
Regret and pain.
Each team will have two hours to create an original song with the theme of
breakups and use the selected three words in your lyrics that were suggested by
our followers. I hope you all have fun and made the best songs.
Hey, if anything happens, just go to his room and unplug his computer dude. That
really ants, I haven't had any caffeine like for like the past week.
And then I just drank. Have you ever had a Yerba Hubei? Yes.
I want to take your hip hop influence in the beat and then I will carry it
vocally in an art, like in a nineties, R and B sort of a way. Yeah. Okay.
I think we have to do the step by step.
So let's get any chord progression down first.
What instruments sound do you like? I like the tar. Oh, that's perfect.
Cause I don't know how to do that. You don't okay.
T the words I have to include tear.
Yeah. I'm down to keep it pretty like minor and moody.
Beautiful. Love it. Hmm.
Can I just come what I just did to you? Yeah. Yeah.
That's that's the easiest option. Okay.
Sorry.
Yes.
Let's wake it up. Cause I know it's sleepy. Are you thinking,
okay, I'm getting, I'm getting what's going on. Maybe 95.
Wait,
let me just add some hats for some groove and then I'll send this over to you.
It's so weird. Cause I can hear him. He's like already singing. That's crazy.
All these Volcker recording to start to scream.
No shade, no stress, no fear, no fade.
I'm honestly really excited about these scratch vocals.
Cause I already like have something cool that I'm going to do with them.
And I'm excited to show you the idea just like hit me like that across the base.
[inaudible] second. Sorry. I think I burped in your ear.
I apologize when I'm super nervous.
I burp a lot and we're not talking by the way. This is on the internet.
I understand
crazy.
It's taken me two weeks to write that I usually take forever,
but we don't have times. Hey guys, how are you guys doing?
Awful. That just popped in give you guys a challenge. He,
yeah.
Your team must incorporate a voice message to your song that was sent to us by
our followers.
And you were willing to do it, but I was a coward and I know that,
but you don't know what is going on inside of me and that's okay.
I'm stuck somewhere else.
And I don't think you'll be able to understand later that this is the best
decision that I could've made for us.
Wow. Um, okay.
You don't have to use the whole memo, but you have to incorporate somehow. Okay.
Good luck guys. And see you at the end.
Thank you. Thank you. It was so sad,
but I think we could keep the indie part where she's like,
I made the best decision for me more than like, I'm sorry. I have to.
I'm not the girl we're writing for is not sorry.
My instinct would be to chop it up and trigger it.
Then it could be used kind of like where I would normally do add Linds or
something.
Let's move in that direction for sure.
You got to get writing. What are you doing? Stop, baby.
You got to get right in fire. Okay. I'm out. I'm out.
[inaudible] I can't hear him. Huh?
X is the only word I have left. Okay. I'm just going to freestyle. I don't know.
The next time he'll be me. I'll keep you.
Should I call Brian and I need help with those things. Okay. I'm.
Going to get up. Need help.
Okay. I just want to send him these harmonies. Explore.
Thank you. Good. We're good.
It looks like we have 30 minutes left. Could you send me the hook? Oh,
you're saying bounce this out. I mean, if it's a convenient time,
you know what I mean? Yeah. So here's the thing.
I think that bouncing it out is going to take too much time.
I'll share the tune with you so you can kind of hear where we're at and then
maybe get an idea. I'm just doing like layers and stacks and stuff.
If you can get that over to me within the next 10, that would be phenomenal then
[inaudible] it's not the right harmony, but it's fine. Let's see what happened.
How's it coming on your end.
You get Brian on some of those vocals over how much time did he say?
Five minutes. Ooh.
Can you say that one out? Simon? Which one? Can you take the bed next time?
Harmony out. I can, I can fish. Correct? It is so annoying though.
If you want to, you got this. We got this right here. Ooh.
It's going to get close. I said just delete it. It's okay.
Yeah. Okay. Gotcha.
Okay. Not bad. I think the, I would just make the,
I can't believe we did that.
The wave titled box too. Yeah,
it would be the one that starts right at the beginning.
That's the first free and then box, hook, inbox, hook to,
uh, those can just start at the beginning of the hook. Yeah.
Oh, I'm not getting less. I'm sorry.
I mean, I can share my screen, but we're going have time.
What are we calling it again? I.
Mean, we could call it, break up to break through. We.
Don't have a name for it yet. Oh my God. Oh God.
Okay. I hate corny names.
Let's just call it jealous. How you feel?
I feel like I just blacked out for two hours. How are you feeling?
Where am I putting it? Oh. Oh, you're doing something. Nevermind.
Answer your question. It's a pretend years. I said, how are you feeling?
You doing good?
Yeah, this was, this was stressful. I don't know.
Tell like time went a lot faster this time.
You didn't know the song that well to not receive the book,
the vocals from Brian until literally the very last minute. That was really,
really tough.
We did what needed to be done within two hours.
I'd say we did a great job.
Everyone. Welcome back.
I hope both teams were able to get everything done in two hours.
Now's the fun part.
Let's listen to each other's songs and see what each team came up with.
Let's begin with team evergreen.
[Inaudible] already. Oh man. I'm so nervous right now.
I love the vocal mixing on this. Here we go.
[inaudible] okay.
Cool.
It's a bop, yo
so much great work on the house show. That was fine. I know it was weird.
Like not really getting the chance to even show you that what,
where the production had gotten to. So
he used to be
[inaudible]. You can keep your thoughts. I hate it.
I keep it
[inaudible] Oh my God.
Oh, that was clean. I love those chord progressions.
You got pipes on you seriously. Yeah. She carried it.
The songs are all amazing.
And props to all of you for pumping this out in two hours, which is crazy.
We have posted these songs online and people are already voting as we speak and
let's find out which one of the two songs will be the winner.
This might sound overconfident.
And I don't like sounding like that, but I do think we're going to win.
It just had a character to it. You know,
the way that the sounds are picked and the way that it bounces and the way that
the vocals are mixing, it was newer to recording our own vocals.
And I thought she killed it.
Now for the results. Both songs are very unique with their own flavor,
but there can only be one winner.
The results are in and the song received the most votes.
The winning song for today's song lag is break up to break
through.
Team evergreen, evergreen
I've been talking so much.
I don't think we're going to win dear evergreen and Brian,
they had an amazing song. So it was kind of undenying for the time that we had.
I feel like we crushed it. It was kind of interesting seeing their rivalry.
What's crazy. Is that because we could hear each other.
I think that amped up the competitiveness. I was really happy with, uh,
McKayla's production and it was just fun. I mean, I met with,
I said like you guys saw him was mad catchy you're all right.
Thank you so much for watching. And if you liked this episode of song lab,
make sure you hit that like button and share this video with your friends.
If you want to listen to these songs,
you can go to Spotify and other streaming services.
So make sure you click the link below and listen to the full tracks.
Thank you so much and see you guys next time.